y 200 personas furiosas marchan hacia la
residencia del embajador francés en la
ciudad de java israel de mayoría árabe
en sus pancartas piden la defensa del
profeta mahoma despreciado según ellos
por el presidente majo
protestamos contra la política del
gobierno francés el gobierno que
perjudica a los 1.500 millones de
musulmanes del mundo el gobierno que
alienta a perjudicar a los profetas un
gobierno sin respeto en el objeto de su
ira esta frase de manuel más pronunciada
el jueves en la sorbonne durante el
homenaje al profesor de historia
sanmiguel patxi uno bueno
no renunciaremos a las caricaturas a los
dibujos aunque otros se echen atrás si
todos joaquín con estos comentarios en
referencia a las caricaturas de mahoma
el jefe de estado ha causado una
indignación de parte del mundo musulmana
en egipto turquía argelia líbano los
llamados a boicotear los productos
franceses han sido transmitidos en las
redes sociales en qatar y kuwait varias
cadenas de supermercados han retirado
mercancías francesas de su cesta
otra atmósfera en la franja de gaza
donde un puñado de manifestantes
quemaron retratos de mayor mac con el
sábado por la noche